long-awaited reunion a school principal
welcomes back his students after a whole
month yeah I have really missed my
school and I'm excited to meet my
teachers and friends to see them again
is a very very big pleasure but much has
changed social distancing is still
required and parents are no longer
allowed to drop off their children
inside the school worried about the kids
in the in the virus right now so I'm
happy but I'm worried at the same time
however excited the kids are to see
their friends again
hugging is not allowed instead they have
to wash their hands properly and sit in
the classroom two metres apart which
requires spreading the children to more
rooms been out hiring young students to
come in and supply our normal staff to
have enough staff apart from schools
nurseries are also opening today but
only half of them are ready to welcome
kids
due to the new health requirements with
extra cleaning less furniture and more
outdoor classes the rest will open in
the coming days the kitchen is closed it
says this used to be the kitchen area
for children having breakfast in the
morning it's only kids under 11 years
old who are back at schools in Denmark
the rest are still at home and these are
the lockers for the kids their jackets
and shoes are here but they're no longer
allowed to be here in order to avoid
them standing too close to each other
while the children here are happy being
back others are at home thousands of
parents are refusing to send their kids
to school I'm responsible not the state
not the kindergarten and I'm responsible
Catrin will keep her children at home
from nursery and school for the next few
weeks perhaps months I'm worried about
the virus of course and we've been
protecting our kids for the last months
like Matt and now they're supposed to go
ahead of it all and I'm also worried
about the scenario they'll meet based on
fear and distance which is not natural
for a child
back at the school is time for a short
break
Molly don't get too close to each other
but the children are only allowed to
play small groups of four I feel bad for
the kids because they want to play
together and they are not allowed to
play together see me John al Jazeera
Copenhagen